[Applause]
the bermuda triangle
contains some of the deepest trenches in
the world
the puerto rico trench at the triangle
southern point
reaches depths of over 27 000 feet
but dr gallagher suspects that mabel may
frequent
the tongue of the ocean a steep
underwater trench
less than a mile away from rose island
the deepest branch of the great bahama
canyon it's named for its shape
that's like a tongue the tongue of the
ocean
drops off steeply just a half a mile or
so
offshore goes from about 30 feet to 300
to thousands
really quickly we really have no idea
what's going on
down in the deep trenches here anything
could be happening in the deep sea it's
one of the final frontiers for human
exploration
even more interesting in my opinion than
exploring space
so animals of all sorts can live within
this trench and it seems like there's
reports of all kinds of different
creatures living within the tongue of
the ocean
it's sort of become this legendary spot
if mabel is in the bermuda trenches she
may not be alone
once thought to be a barren zone with
few life forms
able to sustain themselves without the
sun's light
marine biologists have discovered that
the deep waters of the bermuda triangle
are home to other sharks from the mega
mouth
to the sharp nose sevengill
among the diverse shark population in
the depths of the bermuda triangle
one small shark stands out for its
audacious attacks
the cookie cutter shark a terrifying
shark
with a deceptively sweet name
guys have very distinctive teeth the
teeth are actually fused together each
individual tooth is fused together
unlike what you see with other sharks
this rarely photograph
shark makes dramatic vertical migrations
during the day
it dwells in depths of over three
thousand feet
but at night it rises up over two
thousand feet
to hunt if you look on the underside of
a cookie cutter shark it actually has
cells that produce
light what's called bioluminescence when
a predator sees the bioluminescence in
the water
it goes over it to see if anything's
been disturbed a cookie cutter shark
uses this opportunity
to latch onto the side of these
predators and take a bite from it
the cookie cutter only grows to 20
inches
it has the audacity to attack whales
tuna even great white sharks
the proof is in the telltale injury the
cookie cutter leaves on its victim
a hole in the skin about the size and
shape
of a cookie if you ever looked at how
they get cookie dough
out of something it's with a scoop and
that's basically what these sharks do
they have this jaw structure that can
latch onto the side of an animal and
like scoop out a piece of flesh
[Music]
the cookie cutter shark spends its days
deep in the ocean
but even at shallower depths these
sharks can be extremely difficult to
locate
[Music]
you